[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mardi 21 mai très heureux
de vous retrouver pour le 7-8 journal de
tv 78 voici les titres de cette édition
le chantier devrait être livré en
janvier 2020 les travaux de
l'établissement de santé mgen à la
derrière arrivent bientôt à leur terme
le site comprendra un pôle de santé
mentale de gériatrie ou encore de
formation
c'est une première en vingt ans les
championnats de france de gymnastique
par équipes sont organisées en
ile-de-france l'événement se tient à
partir de vendredi au vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
présentation en plateau enfin la suite
de nos focus avec les yvelinois au
festival de cannes rencontre ce soir
avec deux réalisatrices l'une est
sélectionné à la semaine de la critique
l'autre dans son long métrage au sein du
marché du film la dernière ligne droite
pour l'établissement de santé mgen à la
verrière en travaux depuis trois ans le
site qui fait peau neuve sera libre et
début 2000 20è les nouveaux pôles
consacrés à la santé mentale sont quant
à eux déjà ouvert visites de l'avancée
du chantier en compagnie d'aurélien
après trois ans de travaux voici les
nouveaux bâtiments de santé mentale de
l'institut mgen de la verrière
opérationnel depuis un mois près de 200
adolescents jeunes adultes et adultes
qui sont accueillis sur ce même site de
12 hectares un ehpad ou encore une unité
de soins palliatifs verront le jour
début 2000 vingt deux établissements
historiques sont regroupés le centre de
santé mentale marcel rivière et le
centre gériatrique denis forestier on a
souhaité tout regrouper sur un même site
pour pouvoir aussi avoir une prise en
charge dans le même esprit un peu
l'esprit village c'est à dire que tous
les tous les services se travaille
ensemble également et avec avec une
prise en charge
la plus optimisée pour nos patients à
nos résidents tout paul confondues
l'institut mgen propose 480 singly soit
20% de plus qu'avant il s'agit du site
le plus important en france en termes de
capacité d'accueil
les patients qui viennent ici sont
adressés par les professionnels de santé
du territoire
80 % ne sont pas mutualistes c'est une
réponse pour la population de proximité
la population des dix villes mais aussi
d'île de france
la particularité du côté du projet santé
mentale c'est que toutes les unités sont
18es ressources spécialisées pour les
autres secteurs pour les collègues qui
travaillent sur le territoire
nous sommes spécialisés dans la
psychiatrie la personne âgée dans la
psychiatrie de l'adolescent et de jeunes
adultes dans la mythologie ou dans la
post urgence par exemple vue sur le
château de la verrière ou encore jardin
protégé permettent un meilleur cadre de
vie aux patients en tout 35 mille mètres
carrés ont été reconstruits
investissements pour ce projet médical à
100 millions d'euros un mot de politique
le sénateur du parti communiste français
pierre laurent était à la verrière il a
rencontré les habitants du quartier du
bois de l'étang un déplacement forcément
dans le cadre de la campagne des
européennes
ms ou font aussi de problématiques
locales
nicolas landry le parti communiste
français en campagne à la verrière
distribution de tracts pour les
élections européennes
échanges avec les habitants du bois de
l'étang la maire de la ville nelly duthu
accompagné de l'ancien secrétaire
national du pcf pierre laurent
j'ai besoin d'aller sur le terrain
comprendre ce que c'est que les
difficultés et les projets aussi d'une
commune comme celle là une commune où il
ya beaucoup de logements sociaux on a
des ambitions de développement culturel
social pour cette ville
il faut en avoir les moyens les
questions européennes semblent loin des
préoccupations du quartier les habitants
s'intéressent plutôt thématiques locales
notamment le projet de rénovation du
bois de l'étang
nous on est contre une démolition c'est
un projet qui a été initié par monsieur
hajjaj d'ancien maire qui a demandé des
démolitions alors qu'il n'avait pas
besoin de faire des démolitions nous on
demande une rénovation du voile étant
une mini révolution du centre commercial
et réversion des logements intérieur le
problème c'est qu'on veut reconstruire
mais ce sera quoi déjà ce sera pas du
hlm
donc ça veut dire que la plupart des
gens qui vivent ici ne pourront pas
accéder à cette invitation
puisque ce seront des habitations à la
vente on n'a pas les moyens d'y accéder
un sujet source d'incertitude sur
l'avenir des bâtiments depuis plusieurs
années rénovation sans ou avec
démolition
la question n'est pas tranchée la ville
va organiser des réunions avec les
habitants soit on tombe sur un projet
commun et tant mieux soit on tombe sur
deux projets et ces deux projets seront
soumis au vote les citoyens du quartier
ma position c'est je défends le projet
qui est majoritaire sur le quartier un
premier projet de rénovation du quartier
du bois de l'étang doit être rendu avant
la fin de l'année et nous avons profité
de cette venue de pierre laurent à la
verrière pour lui poser nos trois
questions à l' approche des élections
européennes scrutin au programme pour
rappel ce dimanche le sénateur présente
la candidature pcf mené par ian brossât
c'est au micro de nicolas landry
[Musique]
nous nous voulons reprendre l'argent des
européens pour le mettre au service du
développement des services publics
on vit dans un continent européen où il
ya énormément de richesses mais elles
sont confisquées aux habitants aux
populations elles servent les les
grandes multinationales on a fait de
l'europe un grand marché pour les plus
grands groupes les plus puissants qui
puise nos ressources qui ne payent pas
d'impôts alors que nous avons besoin
partout de moyens l'union européenne est
évidemment beaucoup trop libérale elle a
été conçue sur le modèle qui a conduit à
la grande crise financière capitaliste
de 2008 il faut changer d'orientation il
ne faut pas quitter l'union européenne
c'est l'endroit où nous à hounoux vivons
nous avons besoin de relations avec nos
voisins
on voit bien avec le break site que ça
ne mène à rien apparent chaos politique
donc il faut changer l'union européenne
parce que si elle reste sur cette
orientation actuelle
là elle risque de disparaître parce que
les peuples ne veulent plus de cette
union européenne l'union européenne de
la concurrence et de l'argent ils
veulent une europe qui soit une europe
où opèrent en respectant les peuples les
nations et en respectant le travail ça
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
[Musique]
puisqu'il va y avoir des élections
européennes déjà en élisant des députés
qui ont envie de la changer et pas en
envoyant au parlement européen soit des
représentants de maquereaux soit des
représentants de marine le pen qui vont
s'allier à toutes les extrêmes droites
européennes pour jeter l'europe demain
dans la guerre et dans le racisme
donc il faut élire notamment des députés
communistes parce que nous sommes depuis
le départ des artisans de cette bataille
nous n'avons jamais accepté les traitez
vous n'en avons voté aucun les traités
ultralibéraux qui font la loi de l'union
européenne actuelle il faut donc aider
lire ces députés là et avec eux mené des
combats pour la défense des services
publics pour des grands projets
européens qu'ils soient des projets
sociaux pour créer les conditions d'un
smic européen tirer vers le haut dans
tous les pays de manière à organiser de
la convergence sociale organise l
égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
dans l'union européenne il ya beaucoup
de beaux projets européens à mener
[Musique]
l'ensemble de nos trois questions aux
candidats à la députation européenne
c'est à retrouver sur notre site
internet ww pour un tv 78 ans comme
www.tv 78 points comme c'est justement
sur le thème de l'europe que se tient
cette tradition chaque année à saint
germain en laye le marché européen avec
cette année une quinzième édition des
exposants originaires des 28 états
membres se sont retrouvés pour présenter
les spécialités et culture de leur pays
et nicolas landry étaient sur place
samedi dernier célébrer l'union
européenne dans la diversité
gastronomique des 28 états membres
l'idée du marché européen
un rendez vous traditionnel pour la
commune de saint germain en laye et
c'est ce qu'on veut démontrer ici tout
est festive et populaire
le but c'est sa montre et cette
diversité des richesses et cette
solidarité entre des peuples qui ont un
pack témoin d'un passé commun
parmi les cinquante exposants la croatie
derniers pays à avoir rejoint l'union
européenne en 2013 avec comme spécialité
les sirops jus et confitures à base de
cerises
un match qui ne cesse comme ça qu'on
l'appelle
une cerise qui est cultivé dans la
région de
nos zadar sur la côte adriatique crois
tu donc une région qui est très
ensoleillé et donc c'est une cerise qui
est vraiment de très grande qualité
autre pays à l'honneur les cosses avec
la ville jumelée à saint-germain-en-laye
r les écossais sont venus avec leur wii
skiller haggis et leurs traditions
culturelles musicales
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
marc sommerer score il y a des choses
qui peuvent marquer et symbolisé
l'écossé l'un des plus important ce sont
les groupes de cornemuse
nous avons quelques produits en
cachemire d'une entreprise locale nous
avons apporté spécialement pour cette
occasion les marmelade et des confitures
qui sont des produits clés de l'eco
l'ecosse le territoire le plus européen
du royaume uni lors du référendum sur le
bric site en 2016 64% des écossais ont
voté pour rester dans l'union européenne
[Musique]
l objectif proposer un moment de partage
pour les parents et les tout petits la
fête de la petite enfance se dérouler
samedi à trappes c'était au gymnase jean
guimier un rendez vous sur le thème des
émotions des ateliers étaient proposés
notamment sur la joie et la tristesse
les propos recueillis par nicolas
dandois en fait dans chacun des pôles
nous avons proposé différentes activités
que ce soit des activités lecture des
travaux manuels des chansons et ce sont
des activités qu'on fait dans les
structures petite enfance que les
assistantes maternelles peuvent faire
chez elle aussi est que les parents
peuvent reproduire aussi très facilement
à la maison
le sport à présent le vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines accueille à
partir de vendredi
cet événement les championnats de france
de gymnastique par équipes c'est de
vendredi à dimanche en événement qui
revient pour la première fois en ile de
france depuis vingt ans pour en parler
trois invités autour de cette table
morgan goulard bonsoir vous êtes l'une
des organisatrices de l'événement
également vice présidente de la
gymnastique elancourt maurepas la gemme
justement à ma droite série halo reach
et zélie leriche bonsoir vous êtes
athlètes vous avez 14 dont vous allez
participer à cette compétition et vous
êtes donc athlètes de la jem est
également votre entraîneur vincent gay
rayon bon sens alors je vais poser une
première question on va faire un petit
tour de table
à quelques jours de l'événement qu'elle
dans quel état d'esprit êtes vous est-ce
que déjà mangane tout est prêt pour pour
accueillir cette compétition
ce serait bien mais c'est pas forcément
le cas non pas forcément un petit peu
stressé mais voilà globalement on a des
équipes qui bossent dessus depuis le
mois de septembre
donc on espère que tout sera prêt dans
les temps on est à peu près bien
à l'heure actuelle donc il nous reste
encore demain et après demain pour
préparer l'événement pour qu'on se fasse
une idée c'est combien d' équipes qui
seront accueillis sur ce vélodrome c'est
à peu près 250 équipes ça représente
mille cinq cents gymnastes qui viennent
de toute la france y compris de l'autre
mère voilà et on est à peu près un peu
plus de 200 bénévoles actuellement sur
le championnat de france et donc on peut
dire c'est ce sera la crème de la
gymnastique française qui sera sur place
on peut dire ça une bonne partie oui il
ya la division 2 1 assist que la
division une étant la meilleure des
divisions nationales
donc en effet on a des athlètes de haut
niveau qui seront là on a des jeunes
filles l'équipe de france qui seront
également là puisqu'elles font partie
des équipes dans la division nationale
une
donc on aura deux normalement du bon
niveau à ce week-end alors et zélie du
coup à quelques jours de l'événement
qu'elle quel est ton état d'esprit ça va
je suis pas trop stressé sait plus si le
jour j que j'ai à stress encore mais
pour l'instant ça va
c'est comme les cette compétition
vincent l'état d'esprit aussi à quelques
jours il est très bon il est très bon il
ya une bonne émulation
on a trois équipes qualifiées pour ce
week-end et les trois équipes
s'entraînent très bien depuis un certain
moment donc on sent les filles prêtes et
impatiente que les derniers résultats
ont été bons ce que eli est venu avec
une médaille au plateau on sort dit à
deux semaines des championnats de france
individuels
on revient avec cinq médailles c'est
historique pour le club donc super
résultat on est très fier d'elle voilà
vraiment prêt juste de de nous dire elie
pour toi ça représente quoi un
championnat de france de participer à
une telle compétition qu'est ce que ça
représente
bah c'est une fierté parce que c'est pas
tous les jours qu'on fait je vous
l'apprends si on a deux dans l'année
donc faut toujours se qualifier il ya
des filles plus fortes des fois c'est
pas
c'est pas sûr qu'on est chaque année
donc bah ça représente tout le travail
de toute l'année et d'y participer à
quelques kilomètres seulement de ton
club on sera à saint quentin en yvelines
sur montigny le bretonneux forcément la
famille peut-être qui sera sur place bon
kit suis peut-être aussi ailleurs mais
le faire à domicile aussi ce que ça une
place importante pour toi bay aura
surtout farrior à plus de personnes
beaucoup plus de personnes qui seront
présentes mais je serai dans la
compétition donc je pense pas que ça
change grand chose à dire il n'y a pas
plus de stress ou peut-être plus aussi
de motivation le fait que la famille
soit présente très bien et comment ça se
prépare justement vincent ce genre de
compétition comment comment se passe la
préparation
la préparation est là elle suit son
cours depuis le mois de janvier
globalement la les compétition commencée
au niveau départemental depuis mois de
janvier et elle se peaufine ses
dernières semaines mois de janvier on
est encore dans dans les mouvements qui
sont pas encore totalement maîtrisé la
cia ça fait trois semaines notamment
après le stade français du viol qui
aurait été une bonne préparation pour
ceux possédant pas de france on est on
est vraiment les derniers détails la
question peut s'adresser aussi à morgane
nouveau à l'entraîneur et morgane la
vice présidence qui a un objectif pour
pour le club de la gemme elancourt mort
pas attention à une nation sur les
résultats on peut commencer par les
résultats avec dansant
ce sera pareil pour l'organisation côté
côté justement compétition représente
trois équipes comme j'ai dit à l'heure
là des divisions nationales une va
tenter de se maintenir en dn1 et va
faire il va falloir faire partie des
neuf premières équipes
c'est le grand challenge on se sent apte
à le faire la deuxième équipe jouera
sûrement une médaille marin division
nationale 4 la 6e tentera sa chance
également ça va être un petit peu plus
compliqué c'est là et et dernière
qualifiée mais mais on espère pourquoi
pas oui place et une équipe sur le
podium et du coup côté organisation à
cette fois-ci quels sont les objectifs
que vous êtes fixé et ben déjà de
réussir cet événement ce sera déjà pas
mal
c'est vrai que pour le club c'est une
première et pour l'île de france une
première depuis 20 ans donc on a pas mal
de pression on est assez attendu du coup
sûr l'organisation
on espère que tout se passera bien que
le public sera content de venir nous
voir et on espère surtout accueillir
encore plus de public habituellement
quand on en province où malgré tout il
ya quand même un petit peu moins de
clubs aux alentours en ile de france on
a un vivier de clubs de gymnastique
toutes fédérations confondues hyper
important donc voilà on espère avoir le
public attendu oui parce que ça fait 20
ans que l'île de france n'avait que plus
ces championnats de france de
gymnastique commence à s'organiser
justement ce retour comment vous avez
réussi à convaincre les organisateurs
j'imagine déjà l'écrin du vélodrome ça
pu les convaincre d'avoir une telle
scène pour pour représenter ces
championnats de france
en fait les organisateurs c'est le club
de gym elancourt meurt pas et on doit
faire acte de candidature au mois de
juin auprès de la fédération propose de
gymnastique et après eux ils choisissent
qu'elles seront des organisateurs des
prochains championnats de france et
c'est vrai que je pense que d'une part
le côté vélodrome nationale les a un peu
convaincus du fait que ce soit 1
l'olympique parler de 1024 etc des
infrastructures sont assez
exceptionnelles d'autre part le fait que
ce soit en ile-de-france comme on dit ça
fait vingt ans donc un peu de renouveau
c'est aussi un bon challenge est
d'autant que vous le disiez le vivier
est important en ile de france
exactement
dommage de ne pas en profiter et puis
enfin je pense que c'est parce qu'on est
un club super sympa et que je voulais
non mais voilà je pense que en effet le
vélodrome a joué à jouer dans le dans le
choix est donc trois jours d'événements
sescoi en gros le programme sur c'est
sur ces trois jours
alors vendredi à partir de vendredi 8
heures 40 la compétition commence
jusqu'au dimanche 14 heures 30 le
vendredi toute la journée on accueille
des scolaires qui viennent des écoles
primaires principalement de saint
quentin en yvelines
donc on a à peu près 600 scolaires qui
seront là sur des demi journées à chaque
fois et ils pourront d'une part
pratiqués sur l'île de loisirs les
activités de gymnastique de découvrir le
freestyle gym le trampoline tumbling etc
d'autre part assister à la compétition
et regarder les jeunes filles pratiqués
sur les agréent et les jeunes hommes
n'est pas ce qu'on sait mixte et enfin
échanger avec un athlète ou une athlète
de haut niveau ou ex athlète de l'équipe
de france sur la vie d'un sportif de
haut niveau une carrière la reconversion
poser toutes les questions qu'on se pose
quand on est enfant et qu'on voit des
gens qui ont fait les championnats du
monde à la télé et voilà donc ça s'est
passé
c'est également une compétition et aussi
des animations autour et ce qu'il reste
des places pour venir oui il reste
encore des places
je pense que le gros temps fort ce sera
samedi à partir de 15h30
puisque du coup comme des vincent c'est
la division nationale une et chez les
filles et chez les garçons c'est
vraiment là où il y aura le plus haut
niveau sur le week-end de 15h30 à 20h30
merci morgan goût leur bonne chance pour
l'organisation bonne chance aussi à la
gemme elancourt ment pas et xelis le
riche et vincent la guérison je rappelle
cette date si du 24 au 26 mai donc de
vendredi à dimanche au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
toutes les informations à retrouver sur
les deux sites internet qui se sont
affichés au cours de cet entretien
j'ajoute que le 7-8 l'hebdo de vendredi
sera entièrement consacré à cette
compétition et des reportages également
sur place un débriefing à suivre dans
nos éditions de la semaine prochaine
voilà c'est le moment de notre
parenthèse cannoise dans ce journal
[Musique]
et le festival de cannes ce n'est pas
que des oeuvres en compétition au sein
du palais environ 12 mille
professionnels du cinéma se retrouvent
chaque année au marché du film parmi une
réalisatrice de 27 ans et qui est
originaire de chevreuse jenna sur lui
après des cours de comédie et de théâtre
à paris à londres et los angeles
elle vient à cannes pour vendre son long
métrage il s'appelle l'âge d'or
bienvenue dans le paris los angeles et
saint tropez des années 60 c'est l'âge
d'or c'est l'histoire d'une rencontre
qui va changer le monde empreint
producteur est une actrice un film
tourné dans plus de 35 eu lieu hommage
aux artistes de l'époque des beatles à
brigitte bardot en passant par françois
truffaut des artistes qui venaient des
quatre coins du monde non seulement
français mais également en anglais
américains et qu'ils se rendaient
notamment dans ce petit village à
l'époque qui était un petit port de
pêcheurs maintenant devenu grand saint
tropez et donc c'est la bague on trouve
l'inspiration ils ont vraiment réussi à
changer ce monde qui marchait sur la
tête jeune réalisatrice de 27 ans jen
est à cannes pour distribuer son film en
france et à l'international au sein du
pavillon de l'europe la chevrotine
rencontre également des directeurs de
festivals pour la promotion du
long-métrage
l'âge d'or vient tout juste d'être
terminée et a été projeté au marché du
film et rendez vous c'est surtout les
directeurs de festivals et pas seulement
français rarement en europe en asie en
afrique dans les amériques gréements
dans le monde entier les premiers
rendez-vous ont été extrêmement positifs
les premiers retours sur la projection
sont extrêmement positifs
donc on est vraiment très optimiste et
très fiers et c'est que le début parce
que je suis donc ici jusqu'à la fin du
marché du festival de câbles le marché
du film se clôturera le 23 mai deux
jours avant la fin du festival de cannes
en gros j'ai l'impression qu'à moitié du
temps
tout va mal
et l'autre moitié du temps si famille
dame
tirait déjà la chance à moitié du tout
dans ce formidable
[Musique]
à partir de ce soir et jusqu'à jeudi on
retrouve depuis cannes
hugo casadamont en partenariat avec
radio sensations découverte avec lui de
la réalisatrice cécile ya deux ans pour
son film mardi de huit à dix huit
sélectionnés à cannes
un vent de jeunesse sur la croisette
avec cécilia de ars jeune réalisatrice
et scénariste diplômés des troisièmes
l'institut international de l'image et
du son
deux trappes avec son premier court
métrage produit mardi de 8 à 18 qui a
été sélectionné à la 58e semaine de la
critique
l'une des sélections parallèles du
festival de cannes elle n'en revient
toujours pas je vous propose qu'on
écoute tout de suite et juste après on
découvre un extrait de son film je suis
vraiment très contente d'être ici en
plus la semaine de la critique c'est
quand même une sélection formidable les
gens sont super gentils
je suis hyper heureuse de venir
présenter ce film en plus que j'ai fait
avec une équipe vraiment merveilleuse
logan logan une chance de tomber mais je
leur rende malade excusé dans le casier
demi seconde
ce film parle de les métiers de pions du
métier de surveillant
c'est l'histoire d'une surveillante qui
fait son mieux auprès des élèves qui se
démène avec
dans un collège et qui va faire une
erreur idiote elle va donner une
casquette des objets trouvés à un élève
l acquis cette casquette comme ça je
peux la pole je te dis non pour ça mais
c'est la personne la personne je peux la
prendre et ça va entraîner des
conséquences gravissimes enfin une
bagarre l'exclusion de l'enfance en tout
cas une risque d'exclusion donc voilà le
sujet enfin l'histoire du film c'est
celle là le sujet du film après je
voulais vraiment parlait déjà du métier
des idées que je trouve un nombre de
surveillants que je trouve hyper
intéressant en fait c'est une espèce de
poste un peu hybride
on est à la fois on n'a pas beaucoup de
responsabilités une concrète en tout cas
pas beaucoup de reconnaissance parce
qu'on est considéré entre les adultes et
les enfants on est vraiment dans un
poste où voilà on n'a pas de formation
pour travailler dans l'éducation
nationale c'est vraiment considéré comme
un petit boulot c'est quoi ça doit en
plus c'est de ma faute c'est moi qui
t'ai donné la casquette je le sais bah
ouais c'est pas faux mais non mais si tu
veux je leur dis moi je m'en fous on va
voir la proviseure tous les deux le film
laborde légèrement mais en tout cas
parler de l'autorité des rapports de
hiérarchie avec les enfants du ciment et
enfin deux mesures c'est bien ou pas
d'intégrer cinq ans dans l'éducation
voilà c'était un peu faire un petit
panorama d'un collège un peu normal je
ne sais pas si ça marchera mais en tout
cas j'avais envie de montrer que la vie
et puis chaque soir focus sur un film
soutenu par la région ile de france
présenté à cannes sybille réalisé par
justin triais il fait partie des 21
films en compétition officielle
sybille est une romancière reconverti en
psychanalyste et alors que son envie
d'écrire revient une jeune comédienne la
supplie de la recevoir en plein tournage
elle est enceinte de l'acteur principal
qui est en couple avec la réalisatrice
du film
[Musique]
et puis il va fêter cette année ses 50
ans le club de modélisme de maurepas
organisait ce week-end un tournoi sur
son terrain extérieur le reportage de
marie lehn yapi chinois elles font 35 cm
et honte avec des moteurs de chevaux ces
petites voitures radiocommandées ils
sont très équipée elle concourt tu as
une compétition régionale
c'est une course 80 pilotes et ça va se
dérouler sur la journée ça a commencé ce
matin à 8 heures jusqu'à 18h ce soir
ce matin c'est les qualifications et
dans l'après midi on va faire les
remontées jusqu'à la finale qui aura
lieu vers 17h30 18h
le club de modélisme de maurepas va
fêter cette année ses 50 ans cent trente
adhérents le composent sur trois
catégories différentes
la voiture électrique le seul autre ace
et la voiture thermique
cette dernière fait l'objet de notre
compétition du jour pour laquelle les
pilotes viennent de toute la france
le club est super sympa donc qui
retrouve également l'ambiance avec tous
les tous les potes avec lesquels on
roule en général au club sur le stand de
préparation entre deux courses les
pilotes aussi mécanicien bichonnent
leurs bolides
j'ai entendu de changer ma batterie
parce que là j'ai roulé pour 20 minutes
donc j'ai besoin de changer ma batterie
une passion qui se transmet ici de père
en fils les plus petits entre en piste
au milieu des corps de jeunes vers les
voitures et quand j'ai voudra pas faire
ça m'a donné envie de faire
le jeune mathis prometteur a remporté la
compétition dans sa catégorie
prochain rendez vous pour le club ce
samedi 25 mai pour une course vintage en
intérieur est la fin du set 8 journal
dans un instant vous retrouvez à mélanie
poquet pour son émission le 7-8 culture
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]